today is recall day in california after
years of conservatives organizing
overcoming incredible odds even fielding
a serious candidate with name
recognition with fundraising ability
larry elder today is the day that
californians unhappy with gavin newsom
can go vote him out of office
unless they discover as many
californians have over the past few days
that they already apparently voted
it's quite a story good question what is
going on
we spoke with several concerned voters
here in the west san fernando valley who
believe something wonky had been going
on at places like el camino real charter
high school in woodland hills i went to
el camino high school
to vote
got there at 10 30 gave her this and she
scanned it and said you voted i said no
i haven't
and she said this has been happening all
morning
the man next to me was arguing the same
thing
so as i left i did the provisional
ballot
and i'm just really angry and i saw two
women walking toward me as i left and i
said don't be surprised if they tell you
you've already voted and she said
they've already done that if i voted how
did i vote
and who did you vote for
well i asked the couple
the young women that i talked to and i
said are you in by any chance
republicans
she said yes and i said well so am i
and so are the two friends that had the
problem at vfw
what a coincidence already major
publications are calling the race a lock
for gavin newsom maybe it is maybe it
isn't either way
no one is going to have any trust in the
results no republicans certainly nor
should they
if the past few years of american
politics have given us anything it's a
peak behind the curtains to see just how
removed the way that we're told our
politics works is from the way that our
politics actually works then aoc wears
attacks the rich dress to a party with
all of her rich friends the fec defends
big tech's right to throw elections and
dr fauci that defuchi wants to keep you
off of airplanes unless you take his
shot i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from cool papaj magic
who says
the funniest part of all this is that
nobody is listening to biden his
dictates have no bearing on the way we
live it's like he's only talking to the
blue states at this point it is exactly
like that frankly i'm not sure he's even
talking to the blue states i'm not sure
that joe biden is all that relevant to
the way our government actually works
he's incompetent he messes things up to
paraphrase barack obama but i'm not sure
that he's the one actually running the
show when there's all this sorts of
craziness you know when there are fears
of inflation real inflation going on in
our country
you might want to hedge your investments
with acre gold i love acre gold i love
investing in physical precious metals
i love doing so for as little as 30 a
month but michael you liar gold cost
calm down come down all right you i'm
not lying to you you can invest in
physical precious metals
for as little as 30 a month with acre
because acre allows you to subscribe to
gold bars
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars acre will discreetly
ship the gold to your house acres also
introduced a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar
keeps you updated on your gold stash
every month ships once you reach the
price threshold the big takeaway here
though is that you don't need to come
out of pocket okay i have really enjoyed
investing in physical precious metals
i've really enjoyed investing in acre
gold head on over to get acre gold.com
knowles today start investing in
physical gold make sure you go to that
url because acre is giving away a gold
bar to qualify for the giveaway tweeter
post why you should be the recipient and
mention at get underscore acre that's
getacreal.com
knowles thank you aker gold for
supporting the show they've been doing
this in california for years about five
years ago
back before i fled california i went to
vote in the 2016 election
i show up to vote in my precinct in the
primary and in the primary you show up
at the democrat and republican primaries
are on the same day and you you tell
them your voter affiliation and they
hand you the correct ballot so i walk up
there just sort of automatically she
reaches for the democrat ballot but she
asks she goes democrat or republican i
said i'm a republican she stopped she
looked up at me like i had three heads
like i was crazy then she hands me my
ballot and you get a little ticket that
to show that you you voted the ticket
has a number on it shows you what number
you were in terms of the members of your
party in the precinct mine was i cannot
forget this zero zero zero zero zero
three
a friend of mine was zero zero zero zero
zero five
there's another one i forget where he
was so two two republican friends of
mine and i all in different precincts we
go we vote it's all good general
election shows up
we come to the polling places i say hi
i'm michael knowles i'm here to vote
they say i'm sorry mr knowles you're not
on the voter rolls
i said okay well maybe that's just a
mistake i asked another republican
friend i said hey did you have any
problems voting he said you know i i did
actually i wasn't on the voter rolls
even though i voted in the primary i
asked a third republican friend in l.a i
said hey did you have problems voting he
says yes i did i wasn't on the voter
rolls even though i voted in the primary
so my third friend is a lawyer he
pursues this to no end four months later
he finally gets an answer i think from
the county clerk something like that and
the answer is oh whoopsy daisy clerical
error
whoops so we voted provisionally did our
votes count uh probably not
if the provisional ballots are only
counted much later so uh
no this has been going on for a long
time we called it from the very
beginning of this race we said you know
there's a strange coincidence there's a
hole punched out in the envelope for the
ballot and the whole lines up exactly
over where
you would answer whether or not you want
to recall gavin newsom so you can tell
from the outside of the envelope if
you're going to recall newsome
and what what do the election officials
in california say oh whoops oh it's just
a coincidence no it's a it's a it's a
just a an important thing to process the
ballot and for so you can sign it's not
has nothing to do with where that most
important question is
now we're hearing people voting twice
friends of mine who moved out of
california are receiving ballots
uh still and they're hearing even if
they requested not to receive a ballot
you're i'm hearing stories of people who
are receiving multiple ballots under
their new name under their maiden name
it's just
so
obviously crooked and now we're already
being told they're already pre-emptive
articles from the left saying that the
trump gop election lies are coming from
for newsome no it's a bunch of crooks in
in california who are obviously trying
to rig this thing
i'm not by the way i'm not even saying
the election
is being stolen at the very moment i
just you just don't know it sure doesn't
look good
but the result of this is going to be
that republicans are going to have no
faith in that election nor should they
nor should they there have been too many
shenanigans before our very eyes the the
news story that i just played that's not
from the arch right wing
conspiracy never that's from local news
in california that's run almost entirely
by dems and even they are saying wait a
second what's going on we've been
hearing this all morning
brings me to the top story from last
night which is going to seem like it's
not connected but it actually is
connected this is representative
aoc alexandria ocasio-cortez who showed
up to the met gala one of the most
preposterous frilly silly events of the
year where people wear lots of silly
sorts of outfits and they pay upwards of
30 000 a ticket and they go hobnob with
very rich people
so aoc shows up and she gets the
attention she craves and she wears a
dress that says on the back of it tax
the rich right over her uh derriere you
see it's not on the front it's on the
back attacks the rich and she
co-casually looks over her shoulder ah
yes that'll show the man she shows up to
this very fancy event that says tax the
rich right so p everyone's focusing on
the hypocrisy this is a wealthy woman
who's showing up to a lavish party with
all of her extraordinarily wealthy
friends and she says tax the rich right
and that's this is hypocritical sure but
more offensive to me than the hypocrisy
is the frivolity of it all
we are supposed to believe
that
this clown show this bread in circuses
actually defines our politics oh aoc
that'll she'll show them it's aoc versus
the republicans oh
who's going to win oh oh did you see
what aoc tweeted oh did you see what
so-and-so tweeted today
in fact it's it's just a performance
whatever this woman does
some other silly woman showed up and
said equal rights for women you know at
this at the most establishment of the
establishmentarian establishmentarian
events of the
year this has very little to do with the
way we're actually governed
it this is a sideshow this is a circus
to keep us all entertained so we root
for aoc or we root against aoc and we
all jibber jabber about the dresses
the way our government is actually run
is that some bureaucrat that you've
never heard of at like osha or at one of
the alphabet agencies in washington dc
just writes some regulation that you're
almost certainly never going to hear
about and then that's going to have
effects down the line on some business
and it's going to change the way that
you interact with society it's going to
change the way the economy is run and
and if you're not even going to notice
it because you're going to be focused on
aoc's stupid dress to me that's what so
for us it's so disrespectful not that
aos i mean it's disrespectful that aoc
is pretending to be this people's
champion when she is the darling of the
establishment at the met gala thirty
thousand dollars a ticket but it's it's
more offensive the lack of respect that
these people in general have for
the voters for the american people
who are being denied our
political rights who are being deprived
of our way of life who can't even have
faith in the integrity of our elections
but boy do we have a good sideshow the
other
strange thing not strange if you've been
paying attention
about the met gala
is that none of the people were wearing
masks aoc wasn't wearing a mask
some other lady i don't know i don't
know a lot of these rich fancy new york
society types a lot of famous
politicians and actors and actresses
there none of them were wearing masks
actually the only people who were
wearing masks
were the help
it was the staff
all the staff that were waiting on the
celebrities hand and foot they had to
wear masks to keep their filth away from
the good clean beautiful famous people
the ruling class
they don't want to get those nasty icky
germs from the yucky help
so the help wears the masks
the
anointed ones don't have to wear the
masks even though we're living
is it still the delta that's surging
allegedly or is it the lambda now or is
it the sigma what is it
is it it's the 15th day to slow the
spread or it's the 570th day i don't i
don't quite remember all i know is you
filthy pigs need to keep your masks on
to keep your yucky breath and germs away
from us beautiful anointed people tax
the rich text we're gonna show them
power to the people
what a joke what a joke what a bunch of
clowns i mean they they actually dressed
up like clowns
and then they put on a big circus and
and by the way we fell for it we're all
talking about it
we sort of have to talk about it but if
if i must talk about it
i i do not want to talk about it from
the shallow perspective
that the ruling class wants us to
i at least want to lift back that
curtain i think so much
of the past four or five years has been
about pulling back
that curtain
now we're seeing if you if you tune into
it if you search really really hard
you'll find out the way that we're
actually governed new rules coming up
from the fec
new rules coming out from the irs
that are going to one
undermine election integrity even more
but two
they're going to have a far greater
impact on our actual political life
than whatever
blather comes out of aoc's mouth
when you want to protect yourself
when you want to protect your assets i
would strongly recommend you check out
american home shield i hate thinking
about household breakdowns okay and you
know this if you i'm a recent homeowner
somehow
every month
something breaks okay they happen they
happen more often than you'd like that
is why it pays to have a plan from
american home shield to help cover the
cost of repair and replacing things
like i don't know your ac like your
fridge
like lots of other things in your house
okay american home shield knows that no
two homes are the same that is why they
have new options to help you find just
the right coverage american home shield
members get more coverage options and
fewer exclusions coverage is available
no matter how old your systems and
appliances are okay
right now save yourself hassle save
yourself time most importantly save
yourself money
head on over to american home shield
celebrate 50 years of their providing
homeowners peace of mind you can take
fifty dollars off their most
comprehensive plans ever that is ahs.com
knowlescanawles now to save 50 bucks off
that's ahs.com
knowles for 50 bucks off any plan
service fees limitations and exclusions
apply c plan for details american home
she'll be sure with the shield the fec
the federal election commission has just
finally ruled
or rather refused to rule
on a claim that came out from
republicans many many months ago you'll
remember let me take you back to the way
long ago days of the 2020 presidential
election the most secure presidential
election in american history where
there's no questions whatsoever and if
you dare to question it why you're an
insurrectionist
probably just like the people in
california were daring to question
what's going on in that that recall
election anywho
the way that you know that the elect
regardless of what happened in the voter
machines or wherever else the way you
know that election was at least in part
rigged is that
big tech the people who control the flow
of information around the internet
shut down a negative news story about
the biden family
right before the election
you don't need to talk about any other
aspect to know that that election was in
part rigged by the people who control
our speech which is by definition a
political act you'll remember there was
a new york post story about hunter
biden's laptop and hunter biden had a
lot of incriminating stuff on his laptop
and it showed a lot of
sexual and chemical
indiscretions but it also showed
evidence of corruption
it also showed
it implied evidence of corruption on the
part of joe biden taking money from bad
actors selling government influence
really nasty stuff the the
the kind of corruption that actually
compromises a political order
but maybe you didn't hear about that
story
because if you if you or a friend of
yours tried to post it on twitter first
and later facebook and anywhere on
google
youtube
that would be taken down
you just couldn't do it it was called
disinformation no this is unverified
russian probably disinformation if you
tried to privately message
that that story
you would not be allowed to do that
now it later turned out the story was
100 percent completely correct
oops and they they kind of admitted that
later they said whoopsie daisy yeah i
guess we shouldn't have done that well
the election's over too bad
by the way next time we're going to do
the exact same thing so republicans
bring this to the federal election
commission they say twitter can't do
this twitter threw the freaking election
in many ways
and what is the fec says nope never mind
no big deal twitter did nothing wrong
how about the irs
very few people are talking about this
as well in the three and a half trillion
dollar budget reconciliation monstrosity
that the libs and the squishes are
pushing through the congress right now
there is a little discussed provision
by which the irs will be able to
force banks and financial institutions
to send them
more or less all of your financial
information
not just hey here's my income from the
year here's here's how much i'm going to
pay in taxes
we're talking about
transactions we're talking about
deposits we're talking about withdrawals
we're talking about your entire
financial life and by the way we don't
use cash anymore we everything is
electronic so they're going to see all
the products you make or all the
products you purchase all the products
that you sell who you're selling to who
you're buying from they're going to be
able to get more and more and more data
now the the
squishy shallow republican talking point
of this from the last couple decades is
just going to be about how big
government wants to take more of your
money more of your tax dollars but it's
i don't actually think it's about money
so i mean yes the government wants to
take more of your money yes they want to
control your financial life to control
your broader political life but i think
what this is really about more precious
than money is data it's about data
we are living right now through a major
information revolution you had the
industrial revolution
in the 19th century you had the
managerial revolution in the 20th
century you're now seeing the
information the surveillance revolution
in the 21st century
these these gigantic entities in the
government and outside the government
and kind of working with the government
like google
they know everything about you they know
more about you than you know about
yourself not only do they use that to
predict what you're going to do but they
use that to modify your behavior as well
and the government the federal
government directly is trying to get in
more and more on that action
and power to the people warrior texts
the rich aoc isn't going to say boo
about it
because these tools these hacks of the
establishment
exist
for little other reason than to distract
you
and to put on a good show while the irs
and other
other agencies in
poorly fluorescently lit
hideous brutalist buildings in dc go
about the ugly work of actual government
we talk a lot
about how in china they have a social
credit system we have a social credit
system we do we have a social credit
system that is so
perverse
that even the duly elected sitting
president is sometimes not allowed to
speak
on january 7th regardless of what you
think happened in the 2020 election
donald trump was the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
and a handful of oligarchs took him out
of the public conversation just took him
out completely
that if the social credit system
can silence the duly elected sitting
president they can do it to any of us
and they have done it to a lot of us
and it's not just about
the memes that you get to post on
twitter
it's not even just about the news
stories you get to share it's about your
financial information it's about your
your
geographic information google maps which
was developed
in part with funding from the federal
government and with google which is sort
of a private company but sort of not
doesn't doesn't sound all that different
from china does it and we do have a
social credit system and the libs are
cheering it on jimmy kimmel the other
day
allegedly a comedian is he a comedian he
used to be sort of a comedian jimmy
kimmel now who's hosting one of the
lower rated late night talk shows
came out
and he said that the people who refused
to get the fouchy auchi the people who
refuse to get this hastily developed
drug against the wuhan cough
they do not deserve to be treated at
hospitals
dr fauci said that if hospitals get any
more overcrowded they're going to have
to make some very tough choices about
who gets an icu bet that choice doesn't
seem so tough to me vaccinated person
having a heart attack yes come right on
in we'll take care of you unvaccinated
guy who gobbled horse goo rest in peace
wheezy you're
we still got a lot of pandemics out
there people are still taking this
ivermectin this pois you know the poison
control centers have seen as this spike
in calls from people taking this
livestock medicine to fight the
coronavirus but they won't take the
vaccine which is crazy if you're a vegan
and you're like no i don't want a
hamburger give me that can of alpo
instead
so first of all as as we covered on the
show last week ivermectin is not a horse
drug any more than aspirin is a horse
drug ivermectin is a drug approved by
the fda for use in humans called a
wonder drug by many many people you can
find a lot of studies about it from the
national institutes of health you can
hear wonderful things said about it
everywhere from the cdc to webmd it was
only because some conservatives pointed
out huh maybe we should start focusing
on therapeutics to treat this virus
rather than focusing on a vaccine that
appears to be less effective than you
all promised us it would be
only then did they say it's a it's horse
goo
haha you dummies take the vaccine which
is totally 100 safe except the teenage
boys are 6.1 times as likely to suffer
heart problems from
the vaccine as they are to face
hospitalization from the virus there was
another study from the science that came
out just a couple of days ago but hahaha
you do you unvexed people don't deserve
a hospital bed
hey gay guy you don't deserve a hospital
bed if you get aids hey fat guy you
don't deserve a hospital bed if you come
down with a heart condition or diabetes
hey smoker you don't deserve a hospital
bed if you get cancer hey
including pot smokers by the way i know
now it's easy to ostracize tobacco
smokers because that's politically
incorrect what about the pot smokers hey
you can't nope sorry you can't is that
how we're going to
conduct medicine because in that case no
one's going to get treated for anything
because people
generally speaking
suffer from medical conditions because
of their lifestyle because of their
environments that they find themselves
in they
some of it is just born out of nature
but a lot of it comes from the way that
we live our lives
but no
everyone else who makes
choices gets to be treated
just not conservatives because we don't
score high enough on the social credit
score and now
you're hearing this echoed at the
heights of the federal government the
most powerful people in the government
i'm not talking about joe biden i wonder
if joe biden even knows that he's in the
government i'm talking about the actual
top politician in this country dr fauci
dr fauci who had told do you remember
i'm going to take you back i know i'm
taking you on a real memory whirlwind
today
some
months ago dr fauci comes out and he
says no vaccine mandates vaccine mandate
would encroach on people's liberty we
can't have that and then just like every
other point he made in this pandemic
don't wear masks do wear masks you're
not going to get a vaccine there is a
vaccine you're not going to have this in
time we're going to reopen in 15 days no
actually it's going to take 15 months
actually it's going to take more than 15
months just like on all of that dr fauci
has now flipped his position on the
mandates and he's now saying you ought
not really to be able even to get on an
airplane
unless you take his shot
when i want to get my blood flowing when
i want to get really good american
nutrients do you know where i go i go to
good ranchers when's the last time you
think you had american meat chances are
it's been
way too long much longer than you
believe that you did did you know that
over 80 percent of the grass-fed beef
sold in the u.s is imported from
overseas my friends the good ranchers
have traveled the country on a mission
to help the american family by working
together with local farms and ranches
and shipping straight to your door
goodranchers.com delivers american craft
beef and better than organic chicken
they've got t-bones fillets strips
gourmet burgers and more and at half the
price of online competitors you get the
steakhouse quality you deserve at a
price every family can afford go to
goodranchers.com right now and you can
save 20 bucks or better yet subscribe
and save on each box of mouth-watering
american meats that will show up right
on schedule right to your door i love it
especially the burgers strongly
recommend the burgers they're very juicy
very delicious right now get 20 bucks
off and free express shipping if you go
to goodranchers.com
or use code knowles at checkout 20 bucks
off free express shipping at
goodranchers.com
knowles also go check out ben's show
aoc's let them eat cake
ben focuses on
aoc's outrageous silly dress from the
met gala
tune in tonight to backstage with me ben
shapiro jeremy boring matt walsh and
andrew clayton to catch an all-new
episode of us discussing everything
that's happening including vaccine
mandates how to fight them streams at 7
pm eastern 6 p.m central dailywire.com
and on our daily wire youtube channel do
not miss it we'll be back with a lot
more
hey dr fauci
after
all this time now i guess we're we're
going to be closing in on two years
before you know it
can we finally get back to normal yet
can we finally return to our lives or
are we going to have to or we're going
to have mandates and lockdowns and what
do you think about air travel do you
think you need to mandate the vaccine
for air travel i would support that if
you want to get on a plane and travel
with other people that you should be
vaccinated
i would support that okay
fauci when he was when he was just
heating up that pot of water that all of
us little frogs were in last you
remember we were all in it and we said
oh god i hope you guys don't cook us and
i said no no no we're never gonna have a
vaccine mandate no a vaccine mandate
would be absolutely in it well maybe
just some vaccine mandates no but you
still have your human right to travel
there's no way well actually maybe you
need to get your vaccine to travel what
what is next you're gonna in order to
breathe
in order to breathe the air
in this once free country you're going
to need your shot pretty soon fauci goes
on by the way he's talking about vaccine
mandates he goes on to talk about
vaccine mandates for children
when you
hear us say should you mandate
vaccination for children to be able to
attend school
some people say oh my goodness that
would be terrible to do that but we
already do that and have been doing that
for decades and decades i don't know
what school you went to but the school
that i went to you had to be vaccinated
for measles mumps rubella polio or
otherwise you couldn't go to school
so it is not something new
to mandate vaccines for school children
the solution that we have at our hands
is vaccines
so
what dr fauci has just said here is not
false it actually shows you the
cleverness and the political
ability that he has
he's saying look when i was in school we
had to get vaccines that's true me too
you too i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure for
most people out there you had to get
vaccines too you know look for polio
for rubella
he didn't say smallpox but i'm sure he
would have said smallpox
um
dr fauci do you really believe
that coronavirus and polio are the same
thing are they in any way comparable
polio
you potentially can never walk again
polio turns you into fdr
the wuhan virus especially if you get it
as a kid
statistically nothing's going to happen
you're going to be statistically
speaking you're going to be fine
yes we mandate certain do we mandate the
flu shot no we don't why because the flu
is the flu
we don't so what he's trying to do here
and by the way the flu is a lot harsher
on children statistically than the
coronaviruses so what he's trying to do
is conflate these things that are
totally incomparable
but but all you really have to do is
just rewind listen to all the times that
democrats spoke out lying to your face
opposing the vaccine mandates that they
are now all championing
i'd be pretty surprised if you mandated
it for any element of the general public
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory and no
federal mandate requiring everyone to
obtain a single vaccination credential
we're not counting on vaccine mandates
at all those are decisions the federal
government is not going to make you're
not going to see a central mandate
coming from the federal government
that's not the role of the federal
government you know at the federal level
i don't have the uh
the authority to either mass mandate or
or vaccine mandate that's not what we do
at the federal level definitely not you
don't want to mandate and try and force
anyone to take the vaccine we've never
done that there will be no federal
mandate this is a decision that
historically uh has not come from the
federal government around vaccine
mandates that has not happened ever to
my knowledge
at a national level the no federal
mandate requiring everyone to obtain a
single vaccination credential
these are the people that tell you that
you can't question your election system
these are the people that tell you you
can't question anything about your
government these are the people that
tell you you can't question anything
about what dr fauci says
because dr fauci is the science he
actually said that at one point he said
when i am talking i am
describing the science i fouchy and the
science are synonymous right and boy
that science sure can't make up its mind
can it that science seems to change with
the gusts of wind
these people who lied
to
your face and now continue to gaslight
you about very important stuff about
this unprecedented federal
vaccine mandate
now they're looking at you and saying no
what do you mean i'm president we've had
we always had this
eurasia was a oceania was always at war
with eurasia oceania was always at war
with east asia
this is
the word orwellian is overused but it's
overused because people are seeing
seeing it happening all around us
now in fairness i don't want to be too
harsh on the ruling class right now
because while they are pushing a vaccine
mandate for just about everybody
everybody who's not yet vaccinated
companies with more than 100 people
employees and schools and sporting
events and anyone who wants to go to a
restaurant or a bar or get on an
airplane or you know anybody
anybody
jen saki wants to point out there's one
big exception here
the illegal aliens who are flooding into
our country they don't they don't need
the vaccine why is it that you're trying
to require anybody with a job or anybody
who goes to school to get the kobe 19
vaccine but you are not requiring that
of migrants that continue walking across
the southern border into the country
well look our objective is to get as
many people vaccinated across the
country as humanly possible and so the
president's announcement yesterday was
an effort to empower businesses to give
businesses the tools to protect their
workforces that's exactly what we did
but certainly we want everybody to get
vaccinated and more people are
vaccinated whether they are migrants or
whether they are workers protects more
people in the united states but it's a
requirement for people at a business
with more than 100 people that it's not
a requirement for migrants of the
southern border why that's correct go
ahead yeah that's correct so she dances
around peter ducey's question she
refuses to answer the question but she
she kind of puts on a show she does a
little soft shoe to to pretend like
she's answering the question then ducey
and again he says no i'm just asking
about the very simple requirements
you are requiring american workers to
get the vaccine but even even the
illegal aliens that you're processing
you are not requiring them to get the
vaccine and she looks at him
cold dead eyes she goes yes that's
correct
next question
what are you going to do about it peter
ducey what are you going to do about it
deplorable irredeemable bible thumping
americans nothing that's what
because because
it's it's not up to you it's frankly not
even up to us is what she's implying
these issues are polling terribly for
democrats
this is a political huge loser for
democrats
but the democrats don't seem to care
frankly everything they're doing right
now is a huge loser their immigration
policies their kovid policies their
economic policies they're all huge
obviously afghanistan that seems like a
million years ago doesn't it all huge
losers for democrats and yet they don't
care they don't change course why is
that
one maybe they're not so worried about
losing elections maybe they feel that
the election system is going to protect
them just fine
two
maybe it's not even really them who are
making these decisions do you do you
think joe biden
is the one calling these shots
do you think joe biden knows even which
end is up i don't
and my evidence of this by the way is
that
one when joe biden is answering
questions from the press will say no
they told me to call on i can only call
on or he'll when he's answering a
question he says well they said i'm not
allowed to who's they who's they buddy
but then second of all when he does ask
a question when he does answer a
question
often
the white house whoever is running
things over the white house will just
cut his microphone feed they did it
again yesterday
can i ask you a question of course
one of the things that
i've been working on with some others
is
thank you for joining is what the screen
says joe biden was in boise talking
about wildfires he's talking with some
leaders around there he was asking
george geisler of the national
association of state foresters a
question that obviously has quite a lot
to do with
public policy
but the white house thought no we don't
okay we don't want this out there we're
just going to cut his microphone
just like big tech is going to cut the
microphone of donald trump in a less
offensive in a less adversarial but
still pretty shocking way
the
blob that's running the show is going to
cut the microphone of the duly elected
well
of the sitting president of the united
states what am i allowed to say what am
i allowed to say over here i don't know
speaking of people who are pushing back
against the the blob that's running our
country you've got to give some credit
to ron desantis ron desantis
who is
you know obviously setting himself up to
run for president in 2024 as a
republican
ron desantis just won a major battle in
the courts
first district court of appeals just
granted the state of florida's request
to reinstate the stay
that that would
mean now that the rule requiring all
florida school districts to protect
parents rights to make choices about
masking kids
is
back
okay so what has ron desantis done i
think there are three options here
frankly i wish he went further
the one option is force all the kids to
wear the masks
the second option is
do not force the kids to wear the masks
if some kids want to wear it it's fine
but the schools can't mandate it and
parents can get out of it okay the third
option is ban the masks
i would prefer the third option i don't
think you should be permitted to cover
yourself up like you're wearing a burqa
in afghanistan or like you're a bandito
from the old west okay
it's it's
uh inhuman
it's disordered
and i just don't like it i don't think
we ought to run our lives that way i
don't think that we should muzzle one
another i don't think that we should
stop one another from seeing our each
other's smiles in each other's faces
it's wrong it's it's disgusting those
masks are gross and it's wrong and if it
by the way if the masks really worked if
they really slowed the spread
to the degree
that we were promised that they would
after dr fauci told us they don't work
then he told us they do work and they're
really really important
would we still be in this
perpetual lockdown well over 500 days
later i don't think so i'm not let me
i'll take the fouchy line on this i'm
not saying the masks don't work to stop
a droplet or two i'm not saying that but
as dr fauci also told us people are
fiddling with their faces maybe they're
not using the masks correctly and eve
i'd like to go even further than that
let's say that whatever the media tell
us the science is let's say it's 100
true okay let's say the the masks really
do stop the spread of the virus to some
degree i'm not even going to argue with
that
i still don't like it
i still think that we the people have
the right to govern ourselves and i
still think that we the people if we
don't want everyone to be wearing a
secular hijab or a secular burka really
more like it
i think we have the right to do that i
think we have that political right but
we or we should have that political
right but that has been outsourced to
technocrats and bureaucrats who are
utterly unaccountable
to the people
which this is why i'm so frustrated
talking about aoc's dress i think this
is such a sideshow
this has so little to do with the way
we're actually
governed
it it almost makes you want to turn to
drugs doesn't it well if you live in the
state of washington you can turn to
drugs and it's almost impossible to get
arrested
as of this year it is almost impossible
to get
arrested by a cop for doing drugs cops
can no longer arrest someone for
possession of drugs until the third time
they catch them
this started in february when the
washington supreme court decided that
the state law against drug possession as
a felony is unconstitutional
so this decriminalized drugs then in may
the state replaced the law with a new
law saying it's a misdemeanor
but
still the cops can't arrest you until
the third occasion that you are caught
first time you get a warning the second
time you're given information for a
rehab center the third time you can be
arrested and charged but still
the
governing authorities would prefer that
you do not charge this person that's the
preferred outcome in washington state
and we are told this is a great victory
for freedom
what freedom
the people of washington are not allowed
to pass their own drug laws
yeah it's true you get the freedom quote
unquote of the heroin addict who gets to
shoot up unimpeded but the uh first of
all i don't think that's freedom i think
that's slavery
i don't think the addict would call that
freedom either
the higher exalted political freedom of
the people of washington to pass laws
against this kind of degeneracy in their
state that's gone that's been taken away
from them
outside of an ordinary constitutional
system certainly outside of democracy
sometimes we're a little tough on the
libertarians on this show i don't know
if you've noticed that but i want to be
i really want to be clear about my
language here because all these words
the libertarian and the populism and the
trumpism and the neoconservative all
these words
become a little
murky a little confusing
when people hear the term libertarian it
evokes two completely separate images
sometimes you'll hear a libertarian as a
as a kind of person who doesn't want to
go bomb the middle east you know a
libertarian as opposed to a neocon and
what they mean is the libertarian wants
to stay home focus on
on the american homeland not go and
pursue adventurism overseas
and the neocons they want to go pursue
venturism overseas
but
there's also libertarianism as applied
to the domestic front and the liberty
like on a question like drugs the
libertarian would say legalize all the
drugs
the government has no right to stop you
from using drugs meaning we the people
have no right to pass drug laws
let the guys shoot up that's the height
of freedom
that's the kind of libertarianism that
i'm attacking
because i think it's crazy i think it's
based on a false understanding of human
nature it's based on this idea that we
are free-floating atoms that we are born
primarily with the rights and
entitlement rather than obligations and
duty and responsibility it's based on an
idea that there's no transcendent moral
order and it's based on the idea that
true liberty is pursuing whatever
disordered appetites you have rather
than as the founding fathers understood
the right to pursue virtue the right to
do what you ought to do to have a
flourishing place to not mistake liberty
for licentiousness nowhere did we see
this confusion more clearly than at the
mtv video music awards the other night
with one of the saddest displays that
we've seen in a long time
madonna shows up
in a sort of leather skimpy outfit she's
like a dominatrix you know 50 shades of
grey kind of thing
and
she
is standing there i guess as a sex
symbol she used to be a sex symbol this
woman is 63 years old i don't mean to be
insulting she looks pretty good for 63 i
guess
but she's 63 she shouldn't be wearing
this it's gross don't do it
and this is what our society is now
exalting as the height of freedom
the freedom of a 63 year old woman
to dress up like a
like a woman of ill repute
alone
on stage
putatively for the sexual gratification
of the audience but i don't think that
was actually the effect that's the
height of freedom right
no i don't think so this is i mentioned
george orwell earlier this is really
aldous huxley this is really brave new
world this is
the state coming in and undermining
people's freedom by appealing to their
most base desires which unfortunately is
a product not just of the radical left
but also of the libertarians
who
mistake
pursuing your appetites and your
whatever disorder desires you have for
true freedom and the result of that is
that people now become enslaved to their
sexual desires people become enslaved to
their drug desires people become
enslaved to all manner of selfishness
and they lose the ability to govern
themselves and this is
exploited by bad men who want to rule
over you regardless of your
constitutional order okay
really bad stuff and it's no coincidence
that this has happened with the decline
of religion john adams said the
constitution's built from moral and
religious people it is not fit to govern
anyone else
that wasn't just
a talking point that what he was
observing is that if you do not have
religion and morality to reign in your
basis appetites which are licentious
they're not they're not true liberty
then you're not gonna you're not gonna
be able to attain liberty you're not
gonna be able to govern yourself
so it's no coincidence that we have lost
our political rights as religion has
declined there was a study just came out
there's this yeah i guess it's i guess
you'd call it a study it seems like a
kind of suspect study
it's from the christian post is
reporting on it
study was published by the cultural
research center of arizona christian
university
says that most adult u.s christians
don't believe the holy spirit is real
now look
i'm no statistician
i'm no social scientist
but um
i'm pretty sure a hundred percent of u.s
christians believe the holy spirit is
real
and the reason is if you don't believe
the holy spirit is real you're not a
christian
it's
study
says christians don't believe in the
holy spirit
but
ontology and the definition of words
says they do
because they do because you just can't
be a christian if you don't believe that
but this is this is part of the same
problem that you see in transgenderism
that you see in all the kooky radical
racial ideologies that you see in the
oppression olympics it's the idea that
you
you actually see it in planned
parenthood v casey when anthony kennedy
came out and said that everyone has the
right to define his own concept of
existence you don't you don't have the
right to just define what a christian is
outside of christianity
you don't have a right you don't have a
right to identify as a christian if
you're not a christian you don't have a
right
to do all of these kooky things
but this this identity politics this
ever
less less and less coherent identity
politics is ripping the country apart
you're seeing it on the football field
right now the nfl
has decided this season to debut the
black national anthem at games
there's something called the black
national anthem
and i guess it's the song lift every
voice and sing and they're going to play
it before each game as part of a quarter
billion dollar investment towards social
justice whatever that is so this is a
black national anthem
now whatever
whatever this song is
it's not a national anthem
because there's no there's no nation of
the blacks
right and and the nation that we're
living in right now is is america that's
a so
if this is a national anthem then i
guess the star spangled banner is no
longer the national anthem if both of
them are the national anthem then we
don't have a national anthem actually we
don't have a nation
if a distinct minority
has its own national anthem then then it
is not
part of the broader nation this this was
my issue with juneteenth it was called
the juneteenth national independence day
that's what it's called in the law
which means that it supplants the old
national independence day the fourth of
july
you can't you can't have two national
independence days you get one
you get one you get one nation but it
doesn't seem that we have a nation
anymore we certainly don't have a nation
that in any way resembles
the nation that we had not so long ago a
revolution has taken place and a lot of
people haven't even noticed i'm michael
nolan's the michael knowles you'll see
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show aoc joins
the met gala with a message for all of
her fellow wealthy marxists and we
discuss why the ritzy unearned moral
superiority of met gala really matters
that's today on the bench bureau give it
a
listen